welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and you now locked
into the channel where we break down all
the latest movies new game releases TV
shows and comic books with the release
of Star Wars the Mandalorian on Disney
Plus it's time to go back to a long time
ago in a galaxy far far away with our
new series that we'll be breaking down
everything that you need to know about
the show throughout this episode we'll
be discussing the first entries overall
plot the Easter eggs and its cliffhanger
ending to let you know what could be
happening in the future there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to watch the premiere yet
and don't want to know what happens then
I highly suggest that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into a breakdown of the
Mandalorian okay so the first thing that
you need to know about the Mandalorian
is that it's set five years after the
events of Return of the Jedi the story
on the surface is pretty straightforward
with the Mandalorian a played by Pedro
Pascal being tasked with tracking down a
mysterious bounty that we eventually
come face-to-face with in the climax of
the episode the contract has been taken
out by a character known simply as the
client played by Werner Herzog who seems
to want the asset terminated dulles
comes into conflict as the episode draws
to a close we open with the Mandalorian
on a snow planet that has many similar
scanners to Tatooine and it also has one
of the scummiest places in the galaxy a
bar that we see our titular character
taking a target from it's a great
reprise on the original bar scene in a
new hope with two characters kind of
ganging up on our protagonist but unlike
Luke the Mandalorian isn't here to
apologize and he kills both the villains
trapping one in a door as it's closing
there really should put safety
mechanisms on them it seems like a
pretty bad design flaw anyway there's
also a return of what could be the spy
from a new hope that snitched on Luke
and obi-wan and I took this as the same
character as in that film as they're
both clearly connected to the underworld
and the characters have a lot of
similarities now from the off this
series instantly recaptures the
atmosphere of Star Wars and whether you
love or hate what Disney have done to
the franchise as a whole you can't deny
that they know that
look of the original films with this
opening entry this really knocks it out
of the park and reminds us from the
beginning of just how dangerous these
planets can be the introduction really
keeps up the pace and watching the
mandalorian having to electrify a
creature that has attached itself to his
ship is an awesome way for the series to
get its hooks into you we learn early on
that Mandalorians never take their
helmets off
and apparently this will be true for the
entire series with Pascal not showing
his face once in the season I guess
Jango Fett just liked the feel of Kamino
on his face because he seems to have
dropped that but it also imbues the
series with a sense of solidarity and
gives our character a real mystique to
him that feels akin to dread and Master
Chief from Halo in the basement of the
Mandalorian ship we discover that he has
a Carbonite processing unit that he uses
to transfer cargo and I'm guessing
Bespin must have mass-produced this
because I'm sure it was mainly used for
moving minerals and not for people but
hey it's a nice callback man oh goes to
meet his handler played by Carl Weathers
who assigns him the task to hunt down an
asset for the client it appears that
after the collapse of the Empire fuel
credits and so on are in short supply so
when the handler offers him this
high-paying job naturally he takes it we
see a return of the door scanners that
were in Return of the Jedi and the same
species as salacious Chrome which is
being used as a food source the
Mandalorian also comes face to face with
stormtroopers possessing dilapidated
armor it looks like they become
mercenaries now in the wake of the
Empire's destruction and are working
freelance due to their state and fact
that their clothes are in disrepair
now we don't learn too much about the
asset and exactly why it is but I'll
give my thoughts and it later as we get
further into the recap anyway the client
seems to be okay with the target being
terminated whereas dr. Pershing his ally
who wishes to have it brought in alive
it seems like he wishes to study here
and this could be because of its unity
with the force but I'll get into all
that later
our protagonist isn't the only
Mandalorian in the episode either and we
witness a blacksmith with their symbol
above their door in this scene as also
lip service paid to the Mandalorian
purge though we don't have all the ins
and outs of this it's clear that our
hero lived through it and the purge was
a devastating war that vastly reduced
the Mandalorians numbers it involved the
zone T who at one point
we're allies with the tribe turning on
them and killing them wiping out
warriors families children and more it
looks like our boy was hidden during
this and this is how he survived it
after leveling up he sets off to the
planet where the asset is held and runs
across someone who says that many people
over the years have set off in search of
this bounty but all have failed this
kind of hammers home how dangerous the
asset is and over the last 50 years it
has provided a lot of difficulty for
those that have set out to get it we do
learn that the locals of the planet just
want the bounty gone to stop bringing in
the hunters and mercenaries to the area
and we discovered that this is why our
guide has decided to help the
mandalorian after falling off the horse
pretty literally mano decides to get
back on it and upon arriving at the
compound finds a bounty hunter droid
named IG 11 played by Tyco with tte IG
11 is a clear play on ig-88 the bounty
hunter from the Empire Strikes Back he
was defeated in shadows of the Empire by
dash Rendar but it's great to see
something similar to him popping up here
similar to the Mandalorian IG 11 has to
been commissioned to retrieve the asset
he's probably the standout character of
the episode and whilst he's not as funny
as Korg it's awesome seeing him blast
people and work together with mando Star
Wars was always good at putting together
sidekicks and though his appearance is
very short-lived
he definitely steals the scenes that
he's in watching him constantly go in to
initiate self-destruct mode has a
hilarious undertone to it but it also
showcases just how good the Mandalorian
is when he's under pressure
together they managed to make it past
the guards and get to the asset which is
revealed to be a baby that is the same
species as Yoda and yet all though it's
50 years old as we know from Yoda who
lived to be 900 this species ages a lot
slower than most of the creatures in
Star Wars do IG 11 goes to kill it
because his orders have been terminated
but mando shoots the Android before he
can now this makes me think that IG 11
was commissioned by someone other than
the client and dr. Pershing who didn't
really put mando and a completely strict
orders to kill it though there were
undertones that the client didn't care
either way the Mandalorian stands over
the baby and reaches out his finger
which is when we cut two credits and the
episode
so I actually have a theory that
everyone who has tried to take the asset
so far over the last 50 years has tried
to terminate it and this is why it has
left a wave of bodies in its wake
as the mandalorian does not he does not
fall victim to the same fate that his
predecessors did and therefore is okay
in the end
especially since he demonstrated that he
is there to protect it though we don't
get any confirmation of this due to
things that have been hinted at in this
series thus far I think we can assume
that the creature is force sensitive and
therefore at this time in the galaxy
something that if trained properly
could become a powerful weapon to me
this is why so many people have been
after it and why dr. Pershing wishes to
study it as for Yoda species George
Lucas has never actually given them a
name and nowhere in the Canon do we get
confirmation and what they're really
called this was because Lucas wanted to
keep it all a mystery and the only other
version of this creature that we've seen
is yellow in the prequels and we still
don't know whether homeworld is and so
on this makes it difficult to discern
exactly what's going on but saying as
the only other time we've seen these
creatures they've both been Jedi's there
is potential here that the story of the
show could be traveling the same route
now I may be completely wrong but it's
the only thing I can really assume at
this point in the story from the age of
the creature going forward off the
episode synopsis for the next two shows
we know that the Mandalorian next time
runs into trouble with people trying to
take the acid from him so once more we
can take from this that it is a very
valuable target for episode three the
Mandalorian is said to make it back to
the client and hopefully from dr.
Pershing we will get a bit more clarity
on exactly what's going on now as for
the episode itself I actually really
enjoyed it and the high production
values and engaging plot narrative
really start the Disney Plus platform
off with a bang there is very little if
anything to really fault here and most
of the criticisms that I've seen lobbied
at the show is that the main character
doesn't remove his mask which therefore
makes him difficult to relate to but I
kind of disagree with this boba fett
always had an air of mystery to him and
that is one of the things that made him
so engaging and no doubt this show is
following a similar aesthetic for the
exact same reasons I am already hooked
on this show and this is one back a lot
of the goodwill for Star Wars in me
making a really top-notch first episode
that as far as Premier's go really
stands out as one of the best the
Mandalorian is awesome and if you're
unsure about whether to join Disney plus
or not and this is a strong indicator of
why it's a good idea to sign up
I really can't fault the show and it was
an amazing 40 minutes that I'm desperate
to see more of the Mandalorian episode
one was great and that's why he gets a 9
out of 10
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the Mandalorian episode one
as well as what your theories for the
future are make sure you leave them in
the comment section below because I'd
love to read them and if you enjoy this
video then please give it a thumbs up
and make sure you stay locked to the
channel for breakdowns of every episode
as they're released if you want to watch
us discuss more TV shows in depth then
don't forget to check out our breakdown
of the new HBO series Watchmen which be
linked at the end we go over everything
you need to know about the show so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more if you want to come
chat to me after the video that make
sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey or head over to my
discord server which should be linked in
the description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else then that's the best
place to be it's free to join and we
have an awesome community so hopefully I
see you over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of the Marvel
phase 3 part 1 box set on blu-ray which
contains Civil War Doctor Strange
homecoming Ragnarok and more and all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is like the video make sure that
you subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts on the mandalorian in the
comment section below the winners gonna
be chosen on the 15th and November and
the set will be shipped out from the
intro ever gets the prize it's the best
of luck to everyone who takes part this
is the channel for people who are never
missing television so if that's the kind
of thing you like you need to subscribe
to definition thanks again for taking
the time to watch this you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you